المكوث والعيش على القمر هو ما تعتزم
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا فعله
فبرنامجها ارتميز يرمي الى شيء اول مكان
اقامه للبشر اين على جرم فلكي غير الارض
رغم ان هذا المشروع يتسم بصعوبات كثيره
الى ان شركات بدات تتسابق في مجال تصنيع
الادوات الضروريه لتحقيق هذا الهدف وبعض
الشركات المتخصصه في الصناعات المتعلقه
بالمهمات القمريه ترغب في ان تصبح هي
الجهه التي تزود القمر بالانترنت
وبنظام التموضع العالمي جي بي اس اما
الموضوع الثاني لتسعى الشركات الى تطوير
فهو الطاقه
وتعد شركه استرو بوتيك احدى الشركات
الثلاث التي اختارتها ناسا لتطوير الواح
شمسيه عموديه ايضا وقعت ناسا عقدا مع شركه
ايكن المتخصصه بطباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد
لابتكار التكنولوجيا اللازمه لتشييد طرقات
وممرات هبوط ايضا ومنازل على القمر فيما
تتولى شركات اخرى ابتكار مساكن قابله
للنفخ تحتوي على غرف نوم ومطبخ
بتروحي عادل تسكن هناك على القمر احنا
يعني ما خلصنا نبلش بالاوفرلانت وبعدين
نروح اوفر مود احنا نخلص الارض
احنا خلاص احنا دمرناها تقريبا للارض انتم
دمرتوها احنا قاعد نحاول نصلحها
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه
اشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات